okay let's do it ladies gentlemen once
again welcome back to your favorite
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
ladies John we back at it again and I
got one of my favorite guests coming
back on again during these crazy
quarantine times so I'm really excited
about it and I just want to thank
everybody for listening to the podcast
watching the podcast and once again if
you want to see me game watch me on Eric
Griffin gaming on twitch and YouTube and
I'd really appreciate all the support
for there and continue to watch rhythm
with Christmas but coming to the podcast
now second time guess one of my
favorites give it up for the very funny
to talented yes back on the podcast mr.
Matt D'Elia um one of my favorite
daliyah's from the whole D'Elia clan
diddly a cane is one of my favorite
people in the whole wide world the
favorite people's persons whatever I
don't know how you say it
but anyway Matt's on and once again you
know I have a lot of backlog episodes
because I didn't know how long this was
gonna go what was happening I didn't
know if I was gonna be able to get
guests so I recorded a lot around the
same time so this was like early on
right around when Chris his brother
special came out and then Matt directed
it so I wanted to talk to him a little
bit about that and then Matt not going
to what we love to talk about we like
talking about movies and the industry
the movie industry how movies are made
that he's a real interesting dude I love
talking to him so I hope you enjoyed
this episode and give it up with a very
very funny
just the introspective very smart
engaging dude and I hope you enjoyed the
episode mr. Matt D'Elia
enjoy okay um ladies and gentlemen and
welcome mr. second time on the program
my good buddy mr. Matt D'Elia yeah do so
how you doing I know I know but I think
both of us are in the same boat I think
both of us like every time we've tried
to do this a few times but yeah I just
think it's like the the anxiety and
depression and just like the general
state of like what the [ __ ] is going on
is he it it's kind of getting to both of
us I feel yeah yeah it totally is and
that weird a weird thing is is that a
few of my the
the jobs that I was on before this
happened a few most of them are still
happening so I still have like my gigs
my writing gigs but there's no idea when
they might be made there's no right
right there's no track that they're on
anymore so it's almost like wait when's
the deadline who gives a [ __ ] these
things never get made anyway you know I
feel so so it's like it especially when
it started it was hard to get into a
groove because it was just like what
none of this [ __ ] matters anymore almost
there was almost like this like like
nihilism took over my mind and I was
like ah [ __ ] who cares but now it's
sort of like it's been going on long
enough I'm in sort of a a groove about
it but I have that I feel like you my
brother like real-deal comedians are are
so sort of like it's psychologically so
strange for you guys because your whole
thing is getting up on stage every night
you know and there's literally no end in
sight to this [ __ ] I mean you and I were
just talking about that yeah I mean even
if it just comes to just like
interacting with people this is weird
yes you know I just want to interact
with people and other than my girlfriend
you know yeah yeah it's just and then
that and I don't know man
that's just the psychological effect on
all this like I feel like we're also
fighting not to get used to this yes I
think we're fighting for like no it's
gonna be it's gonna be normal
no we're it's gonna be gonna go back
we're gonna go back and then it's like I
don't know when that's gonna happen so
it just has this weird effect but I've
been telling people like it's okay to
feel whatever you're feeling yeah I know
if you're upset if you're depressed if
you have anxiety it's best to just talk
about it and like yeah address it and
just keep going you know what I mean the
other thing yeah the other thing I think
truly is that it's a leveler in the
sense that it's actually the same it's
not the same experience for everyone but
the same thing is happening to every
single person and I think there's as sad
as that is that's frustrating is that is
for every single person knowing it's
happening to everyone
somehow that takes the personal edge off
and I'm like what would the [ __ ] look
like am I to be complainin everybody's
shut down right right and so it's it's
it's it's a weird it's so weird I still
again yeah as you're saying I don't want
to get you
to it but I feel like we're all gonna
get used to it and then it's gonna end
it we're gonna be like wait what do we
do again what do we do but they give me
the other day my girl just started
crying she just was crying and she was
just like I miss restaurants yeah you
know I mean it was just it was just a
moment I was like oh yeah there's
probably a lot of people that like
whatever it is it hits you it hits
everybody differently could be I miss my
mom I miss whatever I miss doing this I
miss doing that and it just hits you and
you just go because then you start to
like go down a rabbit hole like like I
miss restaurants will I ever be in a
restaurant again like when it happen you
know little day even if it's some stupid
like I was like I missed going to a
sushi I miss sitting down at a sushi
restaurant you know those stupid things
like that but anyway it's not to be
won't be all morbid to hold a
conversation one thing I want to say is
congratulations on your brother special
Michael you do you directed it thank you
and could I was looking at it I watched
it the other night and I was like I
thought about you more than him his
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] but I did I
was like oh nice choice good it looked
beautiful you know look at that great it
was a great that shot that was on him
most of the time was a great full-length
shot
it was just wearing well it was a good
shot coming up from the bottom there but
it annoyed me about the special was he
doesn't understand how x-men Powers work
oh boy X it's so annoying [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of me I hate that anonymously
blastin I don't have to be anonymous
I'll let his ass know I used to hate
true I used to hate also that he used to
do this thing about me oh and how neat
like how Neos powers work and I was like
dude yeah that's not how the powers work
you know he was calling you such a nerd
but anyways but yeah do that it's like
so that you've directed a bunch of
things like this so directing a special
how is that different like how was the
special was
so the idea that the bigger idea that I
had this special the overarching idea
was that like I basically never wanted
to not be looking at him
so my big first fight was like I don't
want any audience camera like I want to
use the cameras we have that's what that
low angle shot was that was gonna be a
floater in the audience now I want to
get that like hero shot of Chris but but
overall the special was all of it it was
my first one I had never directed a
special before but the way it differed
on look almost in a 180 way from
anything else was that all everything is
planning like everything for my job is
like everything get everything in place
and then what it's going it's all him
and we're just trying to capture it you
know I mean so it's like a football
coach yeah do it exactly you stick the
cameras where you stick them and he's
gonna do what he's gonna do and you're
like you can't it's not you're gonna
direct him he knows it better than I
ever could so like it's just about like
getting it you know and as you know we
do two shows and it also I didn't edit
the dude that did Rogen's last few cut
ours
Carlos was his name and he was he was
great but everybody honestly I don't
want to say it was easy because
nothing's easy as you know but everyone
made the job so easy for me to just be
like this is the [ __ ] I want and
everyone was like I feel like on jobs
like that we do get veterans that are so
locked into the [ __ ] that they do for
this certain kind of thing that you're
doing run that you're just like and
they're so business about it there's
like oh that's what you want okay and
then the next day they got like a
[ __ ] previous of it and I'm just like
I guess I'm [ __ ] done like that's all
I gotta do you know so it was a lot of
that you know which is just kind of
about hiring people did you feel like
you were overdoing it at first did you
feel like first I was like at first I
was completely like well these people
all know what they're doing so I'm gonna
shut up for a little bit you know I'm
saying cuz look I didn't want to be the
director ass I didn't want everyone to
be like [ __ ] this guy because they all
know the deal and I'm a newcomer right
and and I and I didn't want to be like
alright this is
we're gonna do I was like I don't know
how these are done like I know how
they're done but also I knew how movies
were made before I ever made a movie
that doesn't mean I knew what I was
doing but like you can know what a thing
is from afar and still suck at doing it
or be green or whatever the [ __ ] so I
was just like well this dude's been a
production designer for 30 years these
dudes have produced like 20 of these in
the last two years like I'm gonna lean
on them and then when it comes time to
[ __ ] start telling people what what
we want what I want to be doing then
it's like all right but I didn't want to
come in all blustery and get started on
the wrong [ __ ] page you know I know I
have one of those like big group
meetings like okay guys just what we're
gonna be doing yes I have a vision just
gonna be telling Joe here's the thing a
lot of directors I think they understand
everyone else is just going to work so
like I get that you have your big
overarching vision but that grip doesn't
give a [ __ ] [ __ ] about it and so he
has to like you you know what I mean he
has to like what you're doing and he has
to like working for you he doesn't
there's need to care about what the [ __ ]
vision you have it's just like you got
to get people to really basically like
you that's why directing is like a
people skills thing more than anything
else oh that's so funny I'm say that I
feel the same way as a performer too
though I feel the same way when it's
similar yeah yeah right right right
come on said I'd like to know the guys I
like I say what's up sound you know you
know that puts you in a you know you
know I feel like in my experience in a
minority of actors who are have like
have empathy for what everyone else is
doing too because I know so many actors
just like they're there they think
everyone's there for them and like
everyone's there to just sort of like
make their job easier and as you know
there's a whole spectrum of [ __ ]
[ __ ] actors you know but yeah yeah
well there's a whole set of [ __ ]
everything but I know what you mean
I do you know it's I was I was doing
this movie I did just Netflix movie and
I was out in Boston and it was like an
hour outside of Boston so it was an hour
to get there it was a whole thing and
then when we're there it's these night
shoots the stars of the movie or kids
so there's hard outs so you know when
there's kids it's like
what does that's that term they use for
kids when they when they have to leave
there's a certain like phrase they say
but it's not just like a talking about
yeah there was a specific time they had
to work so like your crew was just
mainly they were just over it so but I
came to set and I looked around and I
was like oh my god everybody it's cold
so I was doing that thing I'll be like
what's up everybody
yeah and then like I always get a couple
people to come up to me like oh man
thanks for keeping the energy up thanks
for keeping like you know it makes such
a [ __ ] difference
I see yes it really it does make a
difference man you know I got this funny
story for it too today somebody tweeted
at me they said oh man you were in there
was like oh you were in bad therapy man
great job and I was like what the [ __ ]
is that so I look it up and I go oh wow
I did this movie like my years ago and
it was called it was called something
completely different
I didn't know what the movie was about
because it was last-minute and it was
like here's her sides it's like you know
I didn't get to script in it and and I
was like and then I'm looking at the
trailer like it just came out I mean I
just it's such a weird business that
like that's weird I mean that is weirder
I think about that with actors because
actors on yeah if you're trying to get a
movie made
you could spend 10 years trying to make
that thing and then after you make it
two years three years sometimes four
years it comes out later so you're with
that thing the whole time but I always
think about this because I it's not ever
been my experience cuz I'm not an actor
but like to think about an actor coming
on shooting something for like two weeks
whatever they don't have any idea when
they're gonna be seeing that [ __ ] and it
could be as they're saying you could
just forget what the [ __ ] it is you know
I didn't know what it was yeah cuz it's
a different name it's like Alicia
Silverstone and Roy Qadri or they liked
it and it's about and it turns out it's
like some kind of like really dark
comedy that I didn't even realize it was
you know cuz my scenes are with these
kids I thought it was a kids movie and
it was like anyways
just like such a weird but did you see
it you watch it I haven't watched it
just it just came out
so yes me it tells me that they don't
think it's very good the dumb job they
didn't reach out to any of the actors in
a movie later
hey this movie's coming out can you
tweak can you like no it's just like it
just is just out yeah we're on demand I
just I don't I know it's super weird
especially now you should promote this
[ __ ] of it because not you but they
should be because it's like the time
what everyone's sitting around yeah
everybody no matter how good or bad it
is people like I'll watch it yeah yeah
so I tweeted I said I think I'm in this
movie I think we have no idea if it's
good but [ __ ] it might as well watch it
yeah yeah but this reason why I want to
have you on speaking up to transition
into that it's like I live I love
talking about movies with you and it's
like I mean I have you uh have you taken
this time you know to like be like
reinvest in like watching movies have
you made up on movies and other movies
that like so like what are you are you
watching let me ask you this are you
watching guilty pleasures are you
watching art piece movies are you
watching it as a director to be like oh
I've always wanted to see what they were
doing or are you just trying to distract
yourself you know what I mean yeah
that's a good question I would say it's
it's the first two so basically it would
be like my taste is generally like I
mean we talked about a little bit about
this last time but like I like really
really really like
good [ __ ] like like whatever you want to
[ __ ] call it like like uh like I'm
looking at like high-end [ __ ] but I'm
also I either want to see that or like
whatever is in the [ __ ] gutter and on
top of that though I don't think of it
like this is a guilty pleasure or rather
it's so good it's so bad it's good I'm
like this this shitty TV movie from 1990
is just as good as [ __ ] a full metal
jacket or some [ __ ] you know because I'm
liking it just as much so so regardless
of how the [ __ ] they ran into it however
they created a thing that I'm enjoying
this much that's to measure with how
good I think it is so like the things
that I enjoy though and it thinks
certainly that I've been diving into
since all this [ __ ] started is I've been
rewatching particularly like some older
like Brian De Palma movies and I'm
watching like some genuinely shitty TV
movies from like the 80s and 90s which
are really mind-blowing yeah yeah let me
look up the name of this one actually
because it's it's the what it's with
Kate Jackson and Ricky Schroder they're
all they're always like about house [ __ ]
rage rodent yeah dude that's old school
yeah it's old school it's some they're
always about like this one's called the
stranger within okay so it's a stranger
than this woman has her child kidnapped
when he's really small and then she's an
adult she's gonna get remarried she has
no kids and then this teenager comes
back and he's like hi mom and he
perceives to like terrorize the [ __ ]
[ __ ] of her life and it's tip it's like
the most typical script but the
performances are like so insane what I
like about movies like that is that it's
such a weird window into a time and
place that I lived through but forget
you know I mean so like I was a kid in
the early 90s and I wasn't fully formed
enough yet to really understand like
what the [ __ ] vibe of the zeitgeist
was but when you watch something that
was like popular at the time but totally
forgotten you're like holy [ __ ] this is
like a weird portal into what people
thought was cool what style was back in
a certain time
and you start to like put it in place or
put it in perspective like how she got
to where we are right now you don't say
so I'm dying interested in it from a
distance as well yeah I know what you I
know what you mean because then you
start looking at things it's like oh
this is almost a period piece I mean
because we're in LA because we're in
modern times
if you see something like if you see
anything 90s like for me is like I was
in high school I graduated high schools
going into college and you know 1990
right so I'm thinking I'm looking at
that and I'm like but then you do you
think for me and say oh whatever but
then you look and you go oh [ __ ] there
was no cell phones there was me this
there was no that the cars were weird
the style was weird the font and so
sometimes you get lost into all that
kind of stuff dude with the cell phone
thing I gotta say when I'm when anyone's
writing something now a contemporary
thing it I always think about this I
always think about how it's more
dramatic if cellphones didn't exist
anymore like or it didn't exist at all
right so when you want something from
another era they're more likely to have
insanely cool set pieces because it's
harder to communicate it's harder to
warn someone from afar it's harder to
[ __ ] get the cops against the one
else's attention so now when someone's
stranded you got to first hit the or
they try their cell phone thing whereas
before it was like you know they're
[ __ ]
Rainie there's no payphone there's no
yeah yeah because yeah cuz there's an
audience member you're like use yourself
out yeah yeah exactly yeah
oh you have to have some stupid thing
where like the character never charges
their cell phone right right you make
reference to it in the first few scenes
or a sign is always dying and then yes
then you got it that's why you need for
the rest of the movie or you're going
somewhere and it's like there's no
service out here and that's all you need
you know yeah yeah yeah done that so
yeah my girl is watching what she
watched the whole whatever how many
seasons of Gossip Girl
oh my god how is that I've never seen
Gossip Girl yeah I've never seen it yeah
I'm just not I'm just gonna say it's
some of the most terrible like like
there's a John rrah hot people where
that is the prerequisite to be on this
show
yeah number one thing is you have to be
extremely attractive and sexy yeah
acting skill is like not even important
at all yeah some of the worst like
dialog in situations gonna like a soap
opera
and I'm looking at her and she's loving
it you know and I just go so it just
made me realize it was like let me like
that's one of those ones you go this
could be a guilty pleasure
sure yeah that for sure yeah but I but
what I noticed it was like in the
beginning of cellphones because that's
another thing too like yeah early cell
phones were it was like flip phones
young like weird bulky you know or
anytime they go like this they pull out
anything so I don't know I've been
trying to watch I've been watching a lot
of it like weird television shows like
what have you been watching I really got
into this money heist man this Spanish
show that I saw an ad for that I don't
know anyone who's seen that is that
great dude it's a world phenomenon dude
they got yeah okay so I just saw this
little little set this little
documentary thing about it because they
the seasons are over now that I just
watch there's four seasons on Netflix
but the show came out in Spain first
season rave rave reviews lots of
viewership second season it tanked why
can't they canceled the show
our efflux bought it well netflix for
that reason did netflix bought it and
like the actors are talking about it and
that and another one speak English you
know right so the actors are target so
they shouldn't you sub-site whatever now
actors are like just I went from like
you know 2,000 followers to like 50,000
or everyday it was like now there's a
million two million you know and then it
just became the net then Netflix was
like hey key guys do another season yeah
yeah it's just like money heist it's
just like a like a robbery and the main
actor the main guy is like this really
nerdy he's just a nerdy guy they call
him the professor and he's a genius and
he plans this elaborate robbery and it's
just but the show is about like fighting
against the system and then and it shot
so beautifully it's like they use like
colors and like these like you know
these certain cool
certain settings to make the colors that
they're wearing pop and it's all
emotional and I don't know but that's -
I watched all of it already so it's a
cliffhanger and I get to seasons and
they're making a third now
no no they made they made them Netflix
gave them money to make because it was
becoming an editor it's already out now
there's like four or five seasons
available I think it's four seasons but
you know European it'll be like a yeah
like six episodes season or something I
guess so yeah but I've been watching
that and that's pretty good
I've enjoyed that I love a good I love a
good heist movie yeah I'm into the heist
John were the highest genre I feel like
it's kind of its kind of like in a
little bit of a depression like I don't
see that [ __ ] that much anymore those
movies yeah I did I chose yeah like like
I you know it's like heat is one of a
classic movie then I'm trying to is
[ __ ] awesome I watched that movie
about once a year I love movies that you
watch okay yeah that's what we're saying
we would recommend Heat yeah I thought
he was good but there is a part of me
that feels like heat is a little
overrated just because of like it's like
this is like the first time that those
two guys have been on the screen again
in many many years and so here they are
they're supposed to be this like they
they're having this across the table
yeah there's supposed to be this like oh
wow you know Janiero Pacino
but I just look back on and I go yeah I
like it and what well I think a big
gamble that would be takes and I think
this might come down a taste but like
the one scene that they do have together
in the movie as you're saying is so
subdued and you expect the absolute
opposite when you get Pacino and De Niro
together finally for the first time ever
you're gonna expect like this crazy epic
acting thing but the one scene I have
together until the end obviously there's
like they're literally sitting at a
table speaking quietly in public and
it's kind of weird it's bold
that's what kind of I like that it's
bold but yeah I mean it can go you can
go either way with that [ __ ] well in
juxtaposition to like the this like
probably one of the most epic action
sequences in a movie I you know it's
probably an attack I would say it's a
top 10 of a sequencer
of violent action in a movie that you
know the big bank heist part not here
the big bank heist part that was just
such a you know they shot that right
around the corner for me like I said
drive-by with that late because they
shot that downtown and like la they just
shut down the entire grid down here and
you shop for like two weeks it's the
most like involved set piece it's all
like during the day and [ __ ] it's so so
so crazy yeah I love that sequin I see
when I see something like that I always
think of that - I'm looking at something
that I go damn they shot they like how
to date a lie-down how they shoot - you
know yeah that's just days and days and
days and days you know who actually
reference is that a lot is Christopher
Nolan that sequence
he points to as a big thing for the
opening of The Dark Knight that big
heist sequence in the Dark Knight this
is yes [ __ ] cool yeah and also
inception - because there's all that
downtown LA [ __ ] and inception as well
so yeah he loves that [ __ ] so it's got
seeing I like seeing older movies sort
of show up in newer movies not like he's
copying it but like he's clearly saying
I'm using that as a jumping off point
and it turns into this thing we can see
the progression as movies go on you know
I mean I like that and he's good at that
well Nolan changed the genre he changed
the he changed the superhero genre
completely oh yes he flipped it on his
head he it went from cartoony to what he
turned it into yeah you know and then
the dirt and then the Dark Knight the
the cuz I think that that movie went
astray you know I'm not a huge fan of
that movie but the first problem with
you on that yeah yeah the movie went
astray and it's because the guy died you
know he died in an in an impost they had
to change what the direction they were
going in and what does I don't be about
but that the opening sequence of that
movie and establishing that character
that's some of the best superhero yeah
that you know first hour then will be
good I like it yeah you know I don't
count it as a DC movie because they're
so shitty now but what's up with like I
see I don't see the movies anymore
because it does it's so dumb looking but
I see the trailers what are they doing
the closes Hannah
look how arts here's guys I painted that
what when you were seven I painted it to
put in a movie so I had an excuse to see
how shitty the DC movies are the DC
movies yeah okay I see the trailers for
that movie and it's notice it's like
it's like Zack Snyder but like ten times
worse than that it's like taking that
idea of that kind of style that
monochromatic big set these big comic
book II whatever the [ __ ] green-screen
[ __ ] and like just wiping their [ __ ]
ass with it it's so those movies are so
ugly like just to look at them they're
ugly you know this is my problem with I
think I think DC messed up where they
were trying to be like a Marvel so
Marvel set a tone but they set a tone
with um with Iron Man okay so they make
Iron Man they have one of the best
actors of our generation playing this
character and he mean he brought such
life to it yeah but them and all the
movies that came after that where they
were trying to combine them none of them
were good they had a vision yeah yeah
you know they had a vision and they
stuck to it and DC then was like they're
eight years behind and they said whoa we
have to catch up Celeste and they they
shouldn't have done that
they shouldn't have tried to catch up
they should have just done their own
thing yeah yeah yeah I agree I also
think that the overarching style of what
they've chosen
every movie looks like there's a weird
monochromatic blue silver [ __ ] and it's
so like that's your I don't like that
nothing like the way that looks to be
like I'm gonna go see that it's such a
weirdly specific I think ugly choice and
so if they're all looking like that it's
like why would I see one when literally
every single one has this [ __ ] style
what the Aquaman [ __ ]
I saw traffic I was like this is the
ugliest thing I wish is my [ __ ] life
so I don't see those movies either yeah
yes you know that's not your euro you're
not like running out to the theater I'm
a big but I will say this though I will
say this though they that were they made
up for it a little bit is the DC
Universe app oh really yeah the DC is
that because it's like I would say it's
the rate at our branch of DC real AC
yeah usually I recommend it man there's
a there's one there's a there's a show
called Titans and it's like it's like
it's a story of Robin so Robin is left
about man and he starts two Titans but
it's real dark I'm talking about blood
and gore and cursing and sex and really
yeah it's like rated-r Robin and there's
another show that I really love called
Doom Patrol and they tease it they they
introduced it in Titans and then they
have a whole other series and there's a
really good Brendan Fraser's in it
I love reefer oh yeah well you have to
watch this I got a look at them he's
playing a robot in the movie you know
he's sweet has a mask on like he's a
robot but I mean he's supposed to be a
robot but I know the right way like a
helmet but like I mean they show
flashbacks of him but he's really funny
in it and it's like really again it's
dark and grimy so I wanted to it low-key
like that like trying to appeal to a
broader audience with the bigger tech
[ __ ] that's out right in theaters
well I actually I believe that I believe
that this DC Universe like I said it's
they're rated our branch so that you
ever it is comic books and it's like
they're trying to like hit that pg-13
crowd yeah their movies and stuff but
this is where they're like let's be Grom
let's be nefler let's be you know what
is it like premium cable yeah be like
can be considered premium cable so
it's like it's not that expensive you
know if you if you're in they have like
a bunch of card you can you can actually
look at you can actually look at comic
books and they have some really great
cartoons on there so is that only on
yeah like it's not on any other string
blackboard it's only on the app but the
weird part is I was this is how I found
out about it actually this is so weird I
was in Canada doing some shows and I
turn on Netflix and I see DC I see
Titans you know and I was like oh this
is great so I start watching it you know
I get back to the states it's not on
Netflix Oh weird
yeah so it's only internet and it uncut
gems also was on Netflix up there at the
time really and so when I can't so what
I did was and now I lucky I did this I
downloaded I cut gems on necklace so I
could watch it on the plane on the
Netflix app but when I got back to the
states it wouldn't let me view it so all
I had to do was turn the internet off
you know and then like I was like
alright you know me but I but so then I
was like the DC things going I'm like I
haven't seen all the episodes then I
looked around I realized it's in the
States you have to have this DC Universe
app that's so [ __ ] weird dude I mean
I have a big problem with like I just
like let me watch the thing I want to
watch you know like and let it be
streamlined you don't I mean like stop
changing the ship stopped like
splintering off and making another
string platform that I got to sign up
for separate it's like I'm signed up for
like 12 streaming things now and I know
and I forget about some of them and I'm
like oh yeah I have shudder and I love
shudder but I forget about it cuz
there's all these sure I gotta get in
the shutter I love [ __ ] the old
horror movie [ __ ] that's why you have
that its gory horseshit you might like
it dude oh the horror [ __ ] just like
they do originals too like they make new
movies that are kind of I mean they're
low-budget as [ __ ] but I'm into that
[ __ ] I'm into horror stuff you know how
much you shutter is that another $10 $9
a month $7 six is it like less 790 I
think it's $7.99 a month yeah see that's
oh yeah oh yeah I've never bought me the
Disney it isn't into now yeah
Apple TV I don't have a Disney one how
much is Disney do you know this yeah but
here's the thing about Disney though why
it's worth it
so for like the eleven ninety nine or
twelve ninety nine you get Hulu and
Disney Plus oh really yeah so if you
have Hulu and you don't have Disney
you're a [ __ ] idiot you know you were
[ __ ] II did not know that yeah yeah
it'll just be a dollar difference you
got to fix that to get your Disney Plus
cuz you got to watch Mandalorian
Mandalorians good
check out Mandalorian yeah I keep
hearing that shit's good but my problem
with Disney Plus is like they haven't
put out anything else why is that what's
up what do they have I don't know it
doesn't make any sense to me why they
haven't put out there other they
supposedly have all these Marvel shows
they made and they're not putting them
out and I don't know why like Wow all
time they should be why they put this
app out seven months before and they
they they you know they have us wait
each week for mandalorian so once
Mandalore ended you're like okay this is
gonna be great
yeah nothing you know there's a couple
of good movies on there there's a couple
of good Disney family movies that are
actually there's one with a dog I forgot
the name of it but it was actually
really great like a good like do you cry
at the end type of [ __ ] yeah Disney is
the best at making me cry dude any kind
of [ __ ] animated Disney movie I'm
this I'll be crying oh yeah it's just
yeah this was a good one I got a toe go
or a toe go I said oh yeah tell goes any
other way it's really good it's just one
of those like oh you know yeah yeah but
I'm trying to have my list here I like
dishes movies that like I want to go
back and watch right yeah tell me like I
want to watch The Godfather series again
you know I love one and tell ya we don't
watches that [ __ ] every he watches both
the first two every Christmas so I'll be
over there and he'll be like the day
after Christmas is like you say and
today Matt and I'm like I guess I [ __ ]
have to and I always say I'm not gonna
stay and then by the time the night of
the 26th rolls around we're like
wrapping up number two because I stay
those two movies if you have like again
it has to be like a day off like that
but now we all got [ __ ] some days
like 6 hours experience yeah bang out
the first two it's like
it's quite a [ __ ] experience I mean
the third one as you know is not quite
up to snuff but I don't hate it
I don't exactly yeah yeah I hate it but
first or the first two you know yeah
yeah yeah I think if there was some
story things in that one that I was like
what are you doing here yeah but the
first two is like that that that the I
know that we I feel old cuz like you
they say it's like old people talk about
the Godfather yeah but it truly is a
masterpiece yeah yeah of like
cinematography the story acting it's
just like so the Godfather is one of
those I would recommend to people
I recommend the Shawshank Redemption to
people it's been a while since I've seen
that I think about that would be quite a
bit though that's been a while though
yeah that's one I like the hand movies
but what's the movie to you that like
like you go oh I can watch that like I
don't have that many that like if you go
you're gonna throw this on and I'll be
like yeah you know what it is for me the
one movie that like I
I think that casino is the most
watchable movie
honestly casino is the most watchable
movie and anytime it's on at any point
throughout the movie Goodfellas is like
that - I mean there's similar movies
obviously but there's just leave it to
me yeah or like the ones that it's like
oh that's on I'll sit down and just
watch to the [ __ ] end whatever point
it's on like I'm in yeah I was just
gonna say that I put all those movies in
the same there there there
unfortunately so similar yes you know
because he just he uses the same actors
he tells the same story yeah and I love
it I can't get enough but yeah like that
good Goodfellas in casino though those
are yeah I guess those are some good
yeah I'm just trying to think of some
other movies that are like like that for
me if they're if they're just on I'll be
like oh well here we go you know the
comedy version of that is the three
amigos all always watch like from any
point on in that [ __ ] The Naked Gun
the first Naked Gun I'm way to [ __ ] in I
watch those older comedies that I loved
as a kid maybe once every couple years -
cuz I I mean I I can't figure out if I'm
still laughing just because I laughed so
hard as a kid or if that's still my
sense of humor but I laugh like a
[ __ ] you know yeah for me was
the one I liked like that School of Rock
yeah like I don't care where School of
Rock is in the story if it comes on I'm
invested yeah and I and I'm just as
excited when they do their final number
as I am the first time I ever saw it
like that that to me is like what it's
it's one of my favorite movies and I can
watch that at any any point so I'm down
for it at any time you know in general
Jack Black in general is like
the most watchable person for me like
that I feel like would you simply be
Bernie that he's in no I haven't seen is
that the one where is it the one where
he's getting he's getting [ __ ] by the
is that the one
no no that's the d-train which is
[ __ ] hilarious too that it will be so
yeah it's hilarious yeah it's so good
and Bernie's the one where he plays that
like funeral director he's a comedy but
he plays his funeral director who
befriends this old woman and he he ends
up like it's based on a true story and
she disappears and he gets accused of
killing her and it's this dark comedy
same directors School of Rock and he's
so [ __ ] funny innit I can't even
believe how like and it's the kind of
thing where you I see some Jack Rock and
I'm like I you come to value a performer
when you realize like what would this
thing be if he wasn't in this thing yeah
you saying yes you know who else is like
that Bill Murray yeah yeah yeah yeah
since it looks like you are I can't even
tell how good the movie is cuz you're so
good yeah that's like you're making it
you're confusing me basically like the
movies good just cuz you're in it you
know Groundhog Day is one of those other
ones that I could just you could turn it
all you'll be like oh I know where we
are in it let's go
yeah Groundhog Day yes you remember that
movie alive that will be about the
Chilean soccer team yes yes yes yes yes
so that movie and Groundhog Day cannot
on the same day I remember this like
[ __ ] night and day in 1992 it must
have been three baby night high three I
think was 92 and I the morbid little
[ __ ] that I was my family and I were all
gonna go see a movie and I was like we
got to see a live and my parents are
like are you out of your [ __ ] mind
you're eight years old we're not gonna
take you to see alive about people who
ate each other you know true story
luckily YouTube and everyone I got voted
against and everyone my brother and my
parents wanted to grant I did and I was
just so pissed I was like a being a
little shitty kid and we went then I'll
never forget it for this reason but we
went and I
I like died I got pissed my parents
laughing I was and and I was so happy
that I was convinced to not see it so I
have an extra fond memory but now every
time I watch it
that movie specifically stands out to me
is like just actually one of the best
comedies ever made yeah I totally agree
just like it's just but but his
personality like it's like who else
could play that I don't know it would've
been the same movie like he yeah you
know what I mean like it's just his like
smartass remarks and how he deals with
people really makes it what it is you
know yeah that's why Scrooged is another
obscure just like that yeah you know
it's another one you need Bill Murray
you know you know that's that story you
said I have a funny story like that too
when I was a kid my mom she had one of
her friends they wanted to go them I
wanted to go to a movie with one of her
friends and she was like you're coming
with us cuz I'm a little kid I can't
stay home yeah it's you and she if she
wants to go see Raiders of the Lost Ark
hell yeah and I was like I don't want to
see no dumbass way to be stupid man
winnette when I got home dude I wanted a
whip I want to get leather jacket I
wanted a hat and I was running around
the house till we got in a car I would
be like you know dude every kid wanted
that whip every boy water that way yeah
that's just one of the like I used to
like when I when I was younger and I get
on a plane any time we're taking off in
a plane that song would be in my head to
make me like not worry I just be like
where's brother like it'd be like the
climax - yeah man Harrison Ford you see
if we could have a whole podcast about
Harrison Ford movie at that which is
your favorite which is your favorite
Indiana junko my favorite Indiana Jones
oh that's tough man for me tough dude oh
you know I get you template like like
that's a solid choice yeah I mean it's a
solid choice but I think that it's 1a 1b
with the first one in the second one
yeah yeah because the original Raiders
of the Lost Ark is just it does
it's just such a great movie yeah yeah
that [ __ ] on the plane that crazy
sequence Oh on the plane he's like got
off the wing on the wing and sit around
just like every like every fight that
you know every when the plane is turning
and they're trying to escape just every
fight yeah so that that's a solid that
we have and then it just goes off the
rails you know like part three is like
why did they what was the name of three
again what was that one called man well
last for sake yeah that was the one
where they were chasing the the arc not
to arc but the the the the chalice the
the mug of Christ you know that whatever
yeah yeah it was cool to have Sean
Connery as his father I thought they had
a great chemistry oh yeah yeah and it
was a lot of great action sequences but
it just seemed like a retread of the
first - let's take elements from the
first one take elements from the second
one and then we'll put it here you know
so I did one or two were always always
the best and then number four is another
[ __ ] story of that that [ __ ] sucks
the the the Crystal King Crystal scholar
what we don't know what is it called
Crystal stroke were they added aliens
you know and desires in it you got Shia
LaBeouf just being terrible yeah
terrible yeah not for him that's not the
right movie for him you know what I
loved about part two is that was the
last time we that was one of the last
movies that that wasn't the last movie
but River Phoenix is in that playing a
young Indiana Jones oh right whoa cool
and he was great he was amazing
- it was good to the point where you
thought maybe they're gonna young
Indiana Jones right you didn't make a
series like you know but I don't know
what ever happened with that but yeah
yeah that but did any of those but any
of those movies if they come on I'll
watch it even if even if I'm hate
watching you know right yeah I mean the
third one I actually want to watch the
third one again they don't do that
because I don't remember well enough
like the first two but I saw them all so
many times when I was a 40 you know it's
good it's got all the elements man you
know it's got all of the it's got all of
the Indiana Jones elements it's just you
know it's just you just go that's just
not as good as those other two is that
the one is that the one world he's like
going through that kind of maze thing at
the end
and yet to take the leap and jump on
that nice way now okay yeah yeah no it
was like what it was it was uh it was a
leap of faith but it was just like it
was it was just a bridge was camouflaged
with the other side yeah supposedly you
couldn't see it you know but you know he
threw the sand out and I was like oh
there it is you know I mean that I loved
that so much as a kid damn I'm gonna see
I'm into movies like that but there's
some times I don't like when a movie
like Indiana Jones is like here's a
character who's larger than life but
believable that this could be a real
person and when they add magic to things
I don't like that cuz then you go oh now
you didn't tell me that I was watching a
science fiction movie like okay I need I
need to know it was what it was my
problem with this show lost right okay
so when we say magic though you mean
like the writer is just making up some
[ __ ] to be able to do the thing that
he wanted to do or do you mean something
specific by magic like actual magic in
the world yes yes when you when you make
it like you know like you you know even
at the end when you open up the Ark of
the Covenant and this ghosts coming to
life in this universe now you're saying
that you know in your universe there's
real power God is doing something
specific or the devil do that you know
then it changed to me it's a different
movie it is a different it's not just
something unrealistic about it that but
I'm fine with that kind of stuff but
don't go this far in your movie and then
all of a sudden now this happens it's
just my personal thing I don't like if
you agree with you about that
honestly I agree with you about that
because I don't like when movies set up
because every movie sets up its own
rules that's what that's part of this
being any kind of good movie like this
has to set the world and so the whole
example in dealing with yes yes yes so
it by the end or at the end it was just
some different world that the rules of
the world you've been watching are
totally broken that [ __ ] is a big pet
peeve for me yeah yeah I took dude I
don't care what it like I remember even
watching the show I remember watching
Dreamgirls the new one yeah and I didn't
know
musical I know that seems crazy but I
didn't know that it that the movie
itself was gonna be also be a musical
anymore and what I mean by that is
[ __ ] are just gonna start
singing and music comes on breaking a
song like you're breaking a song in real
life
yeah yeah so I'm talking thirty five
minutes into the movie is when they sung
the first song
oh really yes so I was like wait this a
musical you know like because before
that they were singing but they were
singing like there was a microphone and
people right yeah I didn't know that you
could just like right now I could be
like but only at the very end I'm gonna
have everybody break into song it'd be
like a bloodbath and then everybody just
suddenly has a [ __ ] big song and
dance number yeah yeah so I just did you
know I have a problem when but that's
not my only think about the Indiana
Jones movies but I get it like you
suspend your disbelief after the the
first one because like the Ark of the
Covenant thing and then like so then
when you go to Last Crusade and you know
then they made like the the body kind of
voodoo real you know yeah like it's all
about how you present it but I just I
don't like I don't like if you're a
science fiction movie be a science
fiction movie yeah and like I said about
the other of you were into lost that
show well I was into it until I couldn't
watch it anymore because I was like this
is making some [ __ ] up now like just
gonna be like me just okay let me take a
moment lost lost me no pun intended
was the the black smoke what season is
that I don't remember what season it was
all I know is up to this point
everything that was happening on that
island could happen right okay and then
when they had this like magic black
smoke that was monster thing I was like
oh oh so this is now a science fiction
show and so no on now that it's a
science fiction show in your brain you
go anything is possible
like setting up rules is so important
this is about storytelling you as a
director and writer you understand
asleep you know if you if you have
Superman
okay we've established he can fly he
eligible he can x-ray vision he could
see through you know you know you know
and kryptonite hurts him so now that
he's established in the world anything
that's involved with him or around him
could be like that yeah I know so you
you know when you just go something out
of nowhere even in like I don't want to
see vampires in in a [ __ ] Superman
world just right but sudden or it has to
be explained I don't know maybe I'm just
maybe I'm overthinking it
no I mean I think it's I think I I mean
I agree in that you know you don't it's
like in the rug pulled out from under
you and and honestly it's sometimes this
is why I sometimes don't even like
twists because sometimes twists end up
making you think of the whole movie
differently and you're like well now I
have to program watch this [ __ ]
again you know I mean like you just put
it in a different genre now you don't
mean and so now I got a [ __ ] tree
watch it [ __ ] obviously there's the good
version of the twist like 6 cents or
some [ __ ] the legs figure that's it this
is accurate I was thinking this yeah
like that's the good [ __ ] but every once
in a while there'll be a twist that
month you just made this movie a
different genre in the last two minutes
you know I mean it can be a little
tricky is there be speaking of genres
are there genres that you just can't
deal with like you can't watch your
certain genres any any like Jane Austen
type oh yeah old timey you know where
it's big dresses and dramatic but I
shouldn't even say that the costume
dramas dramas I'm out but even after
saying that though the the fate of the
father eat that yeah yeah that was great
yeah so I guess it has to be good but
like sometimes the way it's advertised
it doesn't draw me in when it's some
like I'm tired of the Queen England like
I'm tired of a like another movie or
show about clean Elizabeth it's pretty
unbelievable are you kidding me yeah
really how many of these [ __ ] movies
are there gonna are gonna come out about
Queen Elizabeth
so like I'm a total knows yeah at this
point now but that's the one genre like
that I the Queen Elizabeth John I agree
that's the genre I ain't gon new or
[ __ ] near that [ __ ] it's like we know
this story it's like but but some
you know what's funny about that though
I would say like because the the
repeating the week maybe that's a new
genre we're making up like when you
repeat the same story genre its lip it's
like you know how many Batman's are they
gonna make yeah like how many times my
demands
yeah how many times are we gonna know
that Batman is Batman because his pants
were shot in an alley if I have to see
that one more [ __ ] time one more
[ __ ] time losing Joker dude and by
the way I did that touch that talking
about this I told you what I felt my
problem is with Joker is that what King
Phoenix is 55 [ __ ]
yeah you know what let me get the
correct age I believe you I just didn't
know I don't know but I want to make
sure how old is Joaquin here we go car
key in Phoenix here we go here we go
he's 45 okay he's 45 all right so he's
45 even still yeah yeah if he's 45
Batman in this movie is 10 mm-hmm by the
time he becomes Batman oh yeah in 25
years okay cuz Batman's a he's in his
30s by the time he's like really Batman
yeah Joker's gonna be 70 she's gonna
have a canyon [ __ ]
yeah so I just like I couldn't get past
that so but I get I understood why they
did it it's because what a great
symmetry that when the Joker becomes the
Joker in the chaos he created he created
Batman his nemesis right dad but you
can't do that with a 45 year old dude
you can't just bend the entire narrative
for that one thing yeah it's fine as a
standalone movie but they made so much
money they're like let's make another
one so now you have to explain to me how
to [ __ ] this this just happens that's a
good point that's a good point
I I honestly didn't even get that far
because when I was watching it first of
all the way I think about that will be
is it's kind of similar to the Jack
Black [ __ ] I was talking about because
Joaquin is so [ __ ] good in it that
I'm just like
I don't know what I even think about
this [ __ ] movie because the students
like putting on a one-man show but the
thing that I had the biggest problem
with is that I had to see Batman the
Wayne parents [ __ ] die
oh yeah again yeah yeah that's what I'm
saying dude I was like that's one of
those story plots that I go no don't
know dude it's too many times we all
know it if we're all seen about a movie
we know that [ __ ]
let me see Batman in college I see many
college years you know you know what's
crazy about this cuz Batman's brilliant
the thinly defended they don't emphasize
enough about him is like he's like a
Sherlock Holmes level detective mmm
you know he's a brilliant smart dude and
they're not they're not showcasing that
and it's like you know what's going on
have you ever seen him at that age in
anything never right yes like Jesus he's
in the manger and then he's 33 so that's
one of those Kaba I don't know if that's
a John Rowe but anytime they're like
retelling the same story over and over
again I'm just kind of like just like I
feel like that is no more thing Rob
Robin Hood is another that's
unbelievable to me that that keeps
getting the same tree because that just
sucks that is just not good [ __ ] whether
we're in the [ __ ] couches and [ __ ]
and shooting bow and arrows it's like
yeah we nobody even wants to see that
[ __ ] anymore you know yeah what's going
on here another ride at Russell Crowe
one Russell Crowe one show after that
then they had the Jamie Foxx one did you
see that we're doing - my god it forgot
about that
he wasn't Robin Hood but it's like you
know just the what's really wrong with
you with like the movie business in the
United States is that it sucks that
there's like such a racial element is
always present mm-hmm you know and it's
just terrible but it is what it is like
if you're doing any kind of period piece
if you're doing any type of period piece
and you're talking about it's in the
United States and it's between nineteen
thirty two nine
seventy if you're not addressing racism
in your movie it's not realistic right
yeah and I hate that that's a fact I
hate that that's a thing you know yeah I
mean it's also true of like [ __ ] I
think I was reading something this is a
while ago it might have been like when
Hamilton was becoming a big hit and we
were talking about why like a
Revolutionary era movies about America
don't get made that much and it's
because no one wants to present that
[ __ ] the way it really was yeah no one
wants no studio watch the [ __ ]
finance at fifty million dollar movie
and see that [ __ ] and that I get but
it's like at what point are we just
telling a lie by ignoring like yeah
you're gonna if you're gonna ignore it
that's even worse than recognizing the
touchiness of the subject you know yeah
but some things just don't need to get
made too though well that's definitely
you know it's like you don't see a lot
of Hitler movies you see some good
movies though recently yes yeah yeah
right yeah yeah he's being referenced in
movies yeah but I'm talking about you
don't see like Hitler you know like the
three-hour like a biopic at a certain
point you go okay this is like but it's
the same thing like if you're doing it
it must be the same thing in the German
movie business you know if you see that
movie a downfall the month out there's
like last couple days in his bunker like
losing his [ __ ] no dude it's I think
it's a German movie it's called downfall
and the dude in it was actor bruno ganz
who's [ __ ] rad you thought he's gonna
kind of like Hollywood [ __ ] too but he
plays Hitler you know that that that
clip that was going around where Hitler
was like pointing at a map and yelling
at everybody and there were people would
like change the subtitle they maybe
you're a Giants losing rights that movie
that's that movies yeah yeah that's
downfall but that's the only one I can
think of about Hitler yet by the way
there's is there is a good TV show that
you have you seen hunters on Amazon
Al Pacino I keep being recommended that
show I haven't seen it yet it's good and
there's a Hitler twist oh [ __ ]
down prohibit us that's you know I
really appreciate Pacino in the last
five to seven years like yeah he was in
movies where he was like playing a
character of himself
oh yeah like he was like doing it like
he was doing an impression of Pacino
you know like there was that one movie
about like he was a CIA trainer the
recruit the recruit I know terrible so
you know and he was in and like the fact
in the end of the movie that he was that
he would never for $250,000 he would
never turn on the government it just it
wasn't believable but regardless I hate
when they do that kind of stuff are you
set up who this character is
don't make that guy the bad guy because
right oh you have to give him you can't
do like an Anakin Skywalker turn you
know one second year a hero and the next
second you're killing kids I'll agree I
don't believe you you know but Pacino in
the last like he's done some great work
like playing these characters you know
you know playing these biopic you know
buying pieces and so I think he's I
think he's my favorite actor ever if I
had to pick one oh yeah oh I love him
because kind of cuz what you're saying
because he kind of
we found his path but also just them the
amount of amazing [ __ ] he was in in the
60s and 70s and even 80s is just like
90s - I mean heat was 90s he's but I
love him in that and those kind of the
end that one was towards the end that
was towards I didn't ever towards the
end of his uh it was great and then they
just started to like yeah yeah
and then 2000s was like holy [ __ ] what
is he doing but now he's come back
around yeah yeah yeah yeah I couldn't
even tell you who my favorite actor I
probably have a list of people who I
think are like really tremendous actors
it's hard to say I think you know I
think you just go like like if you think
about sports you go Larry Bird was great
from 80 to 86 you know that see those
seasons were one of the greatest seasons
ever so you know I don't know I mean
sometimes I think I think Leo DiCaprio
has been pretty great in something I
love you know you could look at him and
go like oh he had a stretch of some
really great performances and then it's
like no then you have you know I don't I
don't know it's hard to say does it have
to be someone like that and then you
call of course you got like Daniel
day-lewis that [ __ ] maniac yeah he's
a certifiable crazy person to me to be
able to do what he does you have to be
like what like how does he live I don't
know how we must live so I have a story
about him I was on a location scout in
Texas and the Scout had just worked on
there will be blood so this was a while
ago and she she her her boyfriend was
taking driving him to set and back to
his hotel every every single day and
night and what they were shooting on the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere so he's
staying in this hotel the cupola it's
like a 25-minute car ride out to the
middle of nowhere to shoot those oil
derrick things and there's car full of
kids this is in Texas the car for the
kids cut off their car and he's in the
back but he's like dammit came to you
yeah he's like still in character yeah
and so he's like follow that like follow
those [ __ ] shitty little kids
so he goes and they go they go to this
gas station and the guy the guy driving
is like I don't know how to say no to
them they Lewis and by the way it wasn't
Daniel day-lewis Daniel gets out of the
car and the guys like I don't know what
to do like is this gonna be bad and he
gets right up to the is Daniel day-lewis
as another guy in the middle of nowhere
in Texas yelling at teenagers for
cutting off his car and it's just like
that kind of [ __ ] is truly next level
Minaya next level it's benign yeah it's
like it's like Robert Downey jr. is
character and Tropic Thunder right was
making fun of that yeah but that's it
yeah yeah it's like I saw like every
time he gets nominated for an Oscar and
what's her name not Glenn Close what's
the name of the greatest actress ever
Meryl Streep Meryl Streep any time like
there are the Oscars together like stop
[ __ ] acting like you know you're not
gonna win this [ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah
they're gonna win no matter what they
cannot move yeah man
you probably do you probably liked uh
what was that one he was in he was a
tailor something Oh phantom thread
phantom thread I did like that yeah of
course she's a little it was a little
bit pretentious I mean it was a little
bit like it's just - I don't know I
found myself so that disengaging but
he's amazing in it and so he yeah I'm
sorry to cut you off but I just this is
what I'm trying to bring up to you
you've mentioned just a few times like
how Bill Murray is Joaquin Phoenix in
the Joker and Daniel day-lewis in some
of his movies what my problem is when
somebody is that great and that
distracting from what's going on I think
that's what it is it can be distracting
like sometimes somebody so great at what
they're doing maybe everything around it
is not up to that level so that stands
out to the point where it's like
actually distracting yeah exists when
that character leaves the screen even if
it's just a shot of someone else in the
same scene is that accurate
it can just it can be there's such a
gulf between the quality of when the
person's on screen and whether or not
that you're just like it's it's
discombobulating because you're like
when that guy's on the screen I'm still
entertained he could be talking about
[ __ ] cereal I don't give a [ __ ]
and then when anything else is happening
I'm like what the [ __ ] and I get the
hell out of here yeah but it kind of
reminds me of like you ever see like
kids out on a basketball court that you
know and then there's an NBA player
who's standing there where right yeah
and then other kids who like doing it
and being clear like swats t-ball you
can kind of go what are you doing man
yeah yeah yeah like it you know moved
what I'm saying is it could be that
person's fault even though they're so
skilled yeah basically it's not meshing
with what's going on in this yeah so I
don't know but it doesn't do we've been
it's been an hour you know that you
didn't want to keep listen man I do
appreciate you doing this and I'm just
like I said I'm just trying to put our
content but it's not just that I also
want to take time to like reach out to
people that I like and care about and
like just have a conversation and just
like show people out there that like you
know hey we're normal to we're feeling
the same things that you're feeling and
and we're still trying to stay connected
and it's just like you know it's
important I think it's an important
thing to do to keep doing what we do you
still do it your podcast listen to your
podcast for them Nigeria is confused and
I think is confused
yeah so so make sure you guys check that
out you still doing your podcast I know
a couple times you said man I can't do a
solo episode and we're you know we're
both doing that and I'm treated like
this and it's not the same this better
one here he is but we're trying to make
it is the same as possible but he
you know what I mean so yeah this is fun
I couldn't agree more man I appreciate
you reaching out and it's always fun
[ __ ] [ __ ] with you especially about
movies yeah yeah we'll do it again like
many people are having more organized
but that's I just like maybe we'll watch
some [ __ ] and that's exactly we got it
yeah well I do is like actually right
now guys are they're still looking at
this in the comments right now and I'll
give us like some movies that you think
we should watch will also come up with
some movies and then maybe we'll even
tell people like yo watch these movies
yeah and these are movies we're gonna
talk about and it will have a specific
rundown of like specific movies I'd love
to do that yeah that sounds fun let's do
it yeah man but you listen man stay safe
hit me up anytime and I appreciate you
doing this and we will talk very soon
[Music]
yes
[Music]
you
[Music]